what's going on in that head of yours
something little piece that he said Dad
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love first of
all sir congratulations on the film I
got to see it it is epic it is
incredible it is something you'd be so
proud of but I think what's so
interesting about this one is it's such
a return to form in the sense that yeah
the family is expanding but was so crazy
about this one is you weaponize that
expansion and how the more family you
get the more family you have to protect
talk about what it was like seeing Dom
learn that lesson in this like
installment because it's it's so
cathartic in a lot of ways it's very
cathartic in a lot of ways
first of all
we were
we were entering in production
you know we were all going through this
very arduous time
so one of the concepts was to say
this character that was so accustomed to
having the answers there was a need for
us to relate to the audience
and collectively as a society we all are
kind of scratching our heads and asking
how are we going to raise our kids
in this tumultuous world
and for some reason
that was that that was the concept that
was a seed of saying let's have dumb be
so relatable to the audience that he's
questioning
as you see it's the first time where he
says I don't know what the plan is
anybody that has
family it is what makes us all
vulnerable and anybody can relate to
that
this is a multi-generational saga in the
beginning in 2001 they had no
vulnerabilities
and in many ways Dom was reluctant
to have kids within the Saga
potentially because he didn't
necessarily Trust
where civilization was
you know that anybody that you know that
ends up committing to having a family
when they commit to having a family you
know they're now really invested in
Civilization the future the future the
number one question to ask anybody in
the world anywhere are you
pro-civilization or not I do want to add
this one thing there there's everybody
talks about everyone that you sort of
bring into this but
those barbecue seeds are so sacred in
this franchise and then adding Rita
Moreno to this installment of that that
had to be like if you're going to do an
abuela she really does well think about
that so we added
in the previous film brother and we
added the father that was promised in
the first film
um
in most family structures around the
world
the most
regarded archetype in the family
is the grandmother plain and simple if
we were going to present the most
powerful archetype in the Toretto family
who could you hire
who could you cast
we were so blessed and fortunate to be
able to cast The Incredible Talent of of
Rita Moreno there I remember someone
saying and this is really a trip
that her being in fast 10
and this is deep and people have to
figure this out was the promise
of her
groundbreaking Oscar in 1962.
if you never would have gotten behind
that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today
and now I am the man who's going to
break your family
Peace by peace
I I took inspiration from really weird
things I just imagined what it would be
like to be the devil to me the devil is
something that's like very inviting
something that's you're seduced by
so I don't think there's any way you can
you can play with humor and sexy or you
can play any way you want to but the the
root of it all it's like he obsessed
about destroying Dom on the highest
level and he's had everything taken away
from him so I just you know you sit with
that thing in there and go like this is
all he wants to do is really wear the
skin of Dom he wants to he wants this
family he wants to be like that he's had
everything taken away from him and when
you obsess about someone like that
it's pretty crazy and so I feel like
I wanted to make these colors it was
inspired by these pastel colors this
necklace that my friend made and I uh
built the character on just colors of
like being very inviting and warm and
he's fun and flamboyant and you feel
you're like wow this is something I'm
attracted to and then once you get close
he's absolutely terrifying and then like
the things he wants to do is like it's
beyond
he's so obsessed I always kind of go off
of like animals and then and then I
start with like little weird um
you know the things that uh that really
lean heavy on props and on on wardrobe
to help me get build a character so
I came in with a lot of ideas
and then they liked it and I just kind
of wanted to have this character who's
kind of just
freshly and you know he's just kind of
he just has a low off for everyone and
but then when you get in close he's like
you cannot be trusted and he's like so
evil in my career it's probably the
funnest role I've ever played I did not
see it coming and being like Oh I'm
gonna be in Fast and I'm gonna have so
much freedom and be able to do something
this wacky but yet you know Louis
encouraged it and I really you know had
time a lot of time with the van and
going like Hey My My job is to be the
most horrible villain for you and make
this franchise even bigger and be
something that you just go
you want to take him out but you can't
stop watching them but you're like he
has to die because this is my family and
so it's it's gonna make people just go
like ah I don't like liking them but I
like him and I'm like wow that's
horrible you shouldn't like you just
you're that's what I would want to see
my job is just to be like hey man I'm
just trying to make your story better
and build a better character that just
people want to go like
you don't know how to feel about it
[Music]
I think everyone's seen it except for me
at this point I have a really solid idea
that I pitched to Louis and I'm hoping
it comes true I can't say anything about
it but I think if it was done this way I
think it's going to make him even more
evil I'll say this we didn't get to see
what he was like with his father
but if you were to have
something that was we got to see him
really care about something
and you can see where his his heart is
and then we fall for that
and the audience gets to feel that
then we take it away
and then we get to see what he really
is gonna do
let's start back at the beginning shall
we
Los Angeles 2001 humble roots local kids
Street Racers who became hijacked
so I want to say just with the three of
you sitting here I'm already kind of
just really thinking about seeing you in
this film and how incredible you are and
then also the incredible action
filmography I'm sort of staring at I
will say between you and the marbles
going back to like girl fight I'm gonna
just say a on Flex because people forget
but I will always be a Stan I think all
of you have so much that you've given to
action but I will say with Charlize and
Michelle coming in together to be able
to do that scene that y'all did together
I have to think every stop LED you to be
able to do that because I heard was
mapping that
act setting up the action that day yeah
I mean we definitely didn't have a first
team director
oh yeah our stunt guy we'll talk about
that day said of course like just
starting that when you realized you were
going to kind of be on your own and had
you guys sort of like talk through
that's gotta be a fun morning I see I
feel I mean I feel like by then you've
done so much prep it'd be hard to say
like oh we're gonna do the scene
tomorrow and we haven't really walked it
or blocked it and would you guys do this
without right you set the tone babe to
be fair you set the tone you were like a
machine walking in there and I that made
me feel very secure in knowing that like
no one's nervous about like you know
having to do this you know and that
we're prepared enough to like pull off
you know all the pushes that we put in
for for Olivier and and the the fight
sequence I think you know we did a good
job I just
I'd fight for the like the week prior to
doing the one oh that was a monster that
was really good oh you saw this right
yes I've seen it yeah yeah
everything the elevator all of it and
then I had to fight her yeah she was in
the flow man she talks about fear like I
was like I don't think my 50 year old
boss
don't say that again can we just give it
up again one more time I'm sorry did you
say that really Jesus
can you see that that five zero no I
don't oh no I am almost I'm gonna be 48
my daughters hate when why are you push
I just rounded off I rounded off but you
still but you still are kids
42 forever in my book I
don't continue and now join the family
and like be in the fast franchise I
didn't know this is where you would go
down this sort of like action yeah
imagine how it feels for me
it's really confusing we're all involved
yeah no no but talk about it because you
one thing I will say you're clearly
having fun I can tell you're having fun
with my character and everything you're
doing with her so what are you drawing
upon because I heard maybe it is about
family even in what you're drawing on
when you're playing you know your
version of yes it was literally based
the character off of Ben's family so
it's really a beautiful family
um what does that feel like when you
have first conversation to be like hey
you know just so you know it's her and
then maybe saying it to her even yeah I
I told them right away yeah yeah because
I also just want to be like is it okay
yes I don't want to be a creep
but obviously what it is
um and she's a genius I mean his kids
are geniuses so
um did you get any notes afterwards not
that they would but I'm just curious
um I didn't get notes afterwards but I
got heavily interrogated upon entry
it was they were the three of them on
one side of the table me on the other
and they're like so what will you be
bringing to the fact
one thing I will say when folks do
finally get to see it is I think
everybody in this movie has a moment to
shine there's nobody that sort of
doesn't get that moment of either levity
or action or whatever but I will say not
just your fight scene but every sort of
fight scene within this has been epic is
there one that sort of stands out to you
because I feel at this point you're all
experts on sort of the sort of fast
franchise as far as like cool moments
either you've been a part of is there
one out of this one or any of them that
you're like as we sort of near the Final
Chapter you want to say don't forget
this one because there's a lot of
callbacks I would say that's when
Michelle will start with you I you know
I'd have to say you know hands down you
know all the love that I put in was the
fight with sure at least
um and I feel like you know the reason
for that is because you know I feel like
as a fan I don't get a lot of that and I
feel it right if I feel that way then
imagine you know how many people who
relate to me feel that way and I feel
like you know what I mean we gotta
represent we gotta bring it
seems like a cat fight
yeah like a real fight right yeah that
is the difference we don't get a lot of
that and I saw how much you both did in
that one the camera was right there on
you on so many of those shots they were
definitely not pulling away and I could
do that all day I swear to God it's so
much fun
doing it it's my favorite thing but what
are you talking about you're doing we
don't need words actually fight we don't
need to talk about it just fight it yeah
exactly and I say this to the woman that
produced the documentary on Stunt women
which is incredible
definitely uh check that out but we're
not gonna leave the guys out completely
because there's one guy in this one that
I feel brought a lot of let me just say
Feminine energy to his character and
that is Jason Momoa I want folks to
really see what he does with this
character because it is it is everything
that I wanted to see in a villain and
haven't seen in so long it was it called
back to like Batman villains and like
the best way possible you you felt the
mustache twirling and I know you guys
had fun watching it especially I would
see you shortly like day one the first
thing we shot was him entering my space
and he had a lace shirt
and and he would literally walk and the
lace shirt would just float perfectly
yes bear chest hair floating and what
the hell every time I turned to look at
him I was doing the thing what you were
talking about I was like
and then I'd be like no no no
stay in there you're mean too
but that I meant I was like who off a
lace shirt yeah his wardrobe in this is
going to be talked about everything but
to be fair like if you ever see him in
real life like yeah he yeah yeah he
never forgets his pants he lives in his
own Planet though yeah I definitely dig
that one um I will add this really
quickly because I feel he's somebody
also that's joining in and brings his
own particular energy all of you have
had I think great pairings out of this
is there anyone you want to draft into
the fast franchise maybe like secretly
to myself like I want you to not danger
because I don't really like that yeah
anywhere I go Sam has to go
I would like to see that and I think
everyone else would too that's all I
will say anyone you'd want to drive
Matt Damon yeah I I you know there's
something about his Mr rippliness that I
really like I like how tricky he is how
conniving he is and it's he's just
really good at that he's so good at that
I think he'd make a great villain
he didn't say Ben Affleck let's get both
of them and just like lean in all the
way they would do it don't they doesn't
it soften him when you bring Ben into it
yourself in the who soften Matt don't
Matt you're not
he's such a good trickster man like he's
tricked me so many times I'm like why do
I think you're a nice guy because you're
such a douche in this movie what like I
don't understand and the fact that he
tricks me like that I think would make
him a fantastic villain
um thank you there you go join us
so Uncle Jacob your dad sent me
[Applause]
I'll start with this um you guys get to
really lead into the action this time
and actually do it together what was it
like sort of doing an action sequence I
think with you especially they haven't
let you dabble as much in the action
thus far and you're kind of going into
it with literally a bit of a pro you
know from from his days so what was that
like it was really fun I we were um
training parallel so I didn't really
understand I was like what's John
working on right now don't worry about
John John's upstairs like doing his
thing and then you're downstairs doing
your thing and then you guys have
moments where you connect but it all
like cut together so well and then we
worked really hard to have the brother
sister thing going on and it was just a
beautifully
choreographed sequence that was so much
fun and I'm so glad that everything we
shot is in the film because sometimes
that doesn't it doesn't work that way so
I was really grateful for that yeah they
definitely caught a lot of what you were
doing they could tell from those
close-up shots that it was really you
doing it yeah
Ranger to action films but I think with
this one it is a little different
because there was this whole home
invasion to it it felt like the stakes
were different this time true and and
for me like uh Jacob's about yeah and
very rarely do I get full badassery so
to be able to get into a a fight where
you know I take my lumps and you save
the day thank you very much but usually
I'm getting my ass kicked and trying to
come out alive this and this one was
like full-on badassery so that was that
was very fun yeah you definitely do get
a man on a mission vibe that you sort of
like take throughout this but I will say
before we even get there we start with I
think a very essential part of this
entire franchise which is a very great
heartfelt family moment at the barbecue
and I've heard both you and Michelle
talk about how that's not scripted and
you guys just sort of live in those
moments talk about filming that because
I guess if you're gonna do an Abuelita
that we haven't seen you're gonna do it
with Rita Moreno so that would be a
great one to do it but that does make
unscripted moments a bit harder I would
imagine
um not really because she's a veteran
who's leading the charge so so her
ability to improv and to to bring in
beautiful things along with vin was was
really fun to watch I will have to say
though they had to go guys stop talking
because we'd be like tell us about this
experience you know and and what was
Warren Beatty like and and so so they
did have to stop us from pestering her
because we really we really did I mean
we had a legend on set I think I'm more
thinking about the imitate intimidation
Factor more so than like anything she
would bring you know what I mean because
I'm just like I would like be flustered
talking to her at any moment you know
what I mean it's so warm that after a
couple of hours it was it's just all
gone yeah that's what you yeah yeah it's
just like it's too sad to even think
they could be that talented and then
nice on top of it so that's so great
pretty amazing to hear um I will say
with you sir again I feel like this this
film brings up everyone's talents but I
felt you were especially right at home
playing Uncle there's so much much of
this I don't know if folks know about
your make the wish record but I just
feel like as far as making little kids
dreams come true you've done a lot of
that and like let's be real traveling
across the country with John Cena's got
to be a lot of kids dreams what was that
like for you to sort of like live in
that for a lot of the film well thank
you very much for the kind words uh it
was fun A lot of fast is is under the
gun action and uh what's the next play
and we
we were kind of got we got to lean into
a relaxing road trip at points yeah we
got to really lean into that
cool uncle or trying to be cool you know
it was it was fun it really was fun
um a little bit unexpected but I like it
I like it the one thing I will say
though even though it is like a little
bit of a detour from what we normally
see in fast it is the same in the sense
of like of course you're still going to
get an action sequence of course you're
going to be doing like tinkering of the
tools and a machine gun car you have
your cool moments in this search
Adventure it certainly does but to be
able to
are together or be on a plane together
yeah and have a few moments before the
next cool thing happens it was it was
very very nice
um I will say because I do want to bring
up the machine gun car there's so many
cars in this but that one has got to be
a prop that I don't know how does that
go for you is that how much of that do
you get to play with how much of that is
real because that just seems like the
ultimate big kids toy yeah and it's real
like they made multiple practical
versions wow and something you read and
you're like yeah okay I can kind of see
it and then when you see it really
you're like whoa it's so much better
than I imagined
that's that's hats off to you know the
people making the material for fast they
they love it just as much as we love
being in it just as much as fans around
the world love the movies and they want
to make it the best they can oh yeah and
I I'm so I hope they get that out there
for folks who like take a peek at it
because again awesome when they do get
to see it they're going to want to have
it at home
um for your character in this one again
the moments that we see here it's very
heightened I think everyone in this film
it's under siege of the sort of like
Grand character that is Jason Momoa he
really does sort of set villains in this
franchise apart because he is something
we have not seen or the likes of yet and
I don't think he can be equaled in this
talk a little bit about that for you to
be you've been through so many of these
different iterations what he brings to
the table and really sort of like
changing what we know a villain in this
franchise can be I think what's what's
horrifying about uh Dante is is
given
so like there
like there is hold over him there's
nothing that's going to stop him he just
he doesn't care yeah he just wants to
destroy he just wants revenge and so
and he's funny while doing it which also
makes like this this he has like this
sociopathic Edge to him yeah so he's
really fun to watch
um and yet
so frightening yeah and then for your
character too he's not somebody that you
spend obviously any closer but he is
that threat that really sort of
activates you and I think what we really
sort of see Jacob in this one is is how
far he's willing to go to protect his
family and so he is like the ultimate
Boogeyman in a lot of ways well that's
kind of um you know one of the core
values of fast is the his family and
there's a moment in the trailer it's not
spoiling anything of the problem with
having such a big family is you have to
decide who's safe and that's a great
through line and I think Jason's
character exploits that that one
sentence very well
yeah one thing they definitely talk
about in this franchise so much is you
know who do you want to bring to it who
do you want to like have join the
franchise I actually want to think
of cast there's so many of you and all
of you have a moment to shine but I'm
thinking about you like off type like
someone like you John like you've been
in like I think maybe one wrong combo
like who would you want to cast in like
something different like maybe seeing
Jason in like a horror comedy which who
else in the cast would you like to maybe
see play outside of this sort of like
action genre that we've seen you guys
sort of play out in chapters through
this entire franchise who would you want
to see do something different this in
since the pacifier hasn't done a comedy
I'd like to see Vin in a comedy or a
musical that's actually with a song
Sometimes what Alan said is he wanted to
see Michelle in a comedy and he said
Michelle was actually hinting at that
something that she wanted to do oh cool
so like I think this is like has legs on
it I would like to see you in a musical
Maybe time travel for the next fast and
have the entire cast in a period piece
oh my gosh
whip like
wow you have like thought of us French
Revolution you have thought about this
just saying um
thank you chariots oh my God thank you
for the best answer to this question
Maybe This Is the End
you know what
I smell magic you all I mean where we
are right now shooting this got to
participate in the Italy sort of I'd say
like epic stunt I wouldn't even call it
a stunt it was an event but what was it
like sort of setting that up because
it's crazy that this is the type of
movie where they don't just CGI this you
guys come here you shut down basically
the vat again so
what's that like for a day at the Tyrese
I'll start with you I mean honestly
nothing surprises me anymore I think
when it comes to movies and people don't
really look at it this way but what
better way to Market promote and
advertise your city state or country
than the half Fast and the Furious to
film anything so you know if you were
the minister of Tourism and you had a
budget to promote your movie city or
country or a vacation resort and someone
says the fast and if yours wants to come
to your Resort and take over for a month
you'll be like uh by all means
so it's uh as crazy as it sounds to take
over countries the way we do uh I think
everyone ultimately is happy you know
that's what happened in Abu Dhabi with
furious 7. everybody was like what's Abu
Dhabi the tourism has been off the
charts and we love to have access to
these unlimited exclusive places but the
people that are in politics they know
like man this is going to be seeing
around the world people are going to be
coming to Rome after this film comes out
so why not let them have all access
what was it like being Natalie those
sort of setting up that day because it's
not only just
shot you guys get to do I mean that's
just setting up that stunt I know they
put you guys in those cars even though
they don't have to to Really make sure
you're doing it okay well I think it's
like important to um just say like not
all of that is shopping because there's
a whole second unit
sorry no but like there's a whole second
unit that comes and does the amazing
stunts and like you know not all of us
actually got to come to Rome ah I was
here via green screen oh right
so you know but we have these cool sets
that look like they are just straight
out of the city
though right so that's the first time
you got to come here well I've been to
Rome before the movie yeah like this is
the first time but they tricked us good
baby yeah
hurts feelings
it's movie Magic it's all it's a lot of
it is in pieces and you know also like
you have to for safety contain parts of
it true as well because you can't
necessarily do certain things in the
middle of that again
and you can't I mean we can we can
pretend that they did right there's also
a safety element it's okay yeah but but
because she's so hurt but what I will
say is that I was actually just
independently visiting Rome and I
stepped outside of where I was staying
and walked into the fast set by the way
that was a complete coincidence and then
I saw this guy that kind of looked like
Jason but with dots on his face walked
past and I was like I think I'm on oh
you were here
it was you were in Rome and they were
doing shots they were doing oh that's
why um and then I saw Jason and then I
was like oh this is real so
I think I confused a lot of people
because I'm like wait is she supposed to
be here
I'm just walking
paste
oh that's the script that you didn't get
I got that
I'm sorry
it's so amazing to
think it's so iconic
energy of our movie and the kind of
drama and like the explosions and the
action it's such a great kind of
juxtaposition and to have it play out on
such a stage is like it feels iconic
because Rome is an iconic City to me
anyway and it we've definitely brought
the icon I mean just where they have
this Premiere set up where you guys are
going to be at it's pretty exceptional
um Scott I will say your character it's
interesting every time anyone comes back
it's like no matter where they were in
the last movie they're in a different
place in the next one because it's like
you know they just continue to add to
the family as we like to see little
nobody is in a completely different
place this time around than he was the
last time we saw what's that you just
like hey go big or go home I'm here to
break the law this time I mean it's
really like he's he's switched
allegiances slightly but is that
something that you sort of lean into
because you know your little more fun
stuff oh hell yeah yeah I think it's
great I think that's a fun that's a fun
Evolution for the character I think all
of you have gotten a bit of experience
with this and that is the incredible
sort of like barbecue scene that you
guys got to film so tell me about what
it was like filming that one and just
sort of adding in the little added bonus
of Rita Moreno
um to the mix so yeah talk about that
one Tyrese
foreign
I just could not
get enough of Rita I mean it was like
really
warm and beautiful and she definitely
hit it out the park but you could tell
that these are words
but
that's really who she is she is
beautiful she is warm she is funny she's
got a lot of wit and charm and she also
has a bottom line just like a grandma
it's like no jokes we could crack up
with jokes hey hey
you know so it must have been tough for
you
what about you I saw you geek out a
little bit because you did not geek out
about reading right now
um yeah I had to what quite hard to hold
to kind of just you know be cool
but she was ever so sweet and so like
Terry said so warm and it was because I
got quite a good seat at the table just
like in terms of The Blocking and
watching her no but watching sorry I was
excited I was like I'm so close this is
amazing like up close front row seat to
watch watching her work and watching her
you know just
be the artist that she is like I was a
little in awe to be honest
um and it's always really wonderful
having everybody together as well and
it's it feels like familial it is
familiar but it's good yeah but it but
it and also just because of the way
where that scene is in the movie yeah is
very different this time
um it kind of sets us up in this kind of
warm kind of big warm hug and then it
kind of goes around yeah and usually we
have the big warm hug at the end once
we've been through yeah everything and
it was just such a great send-off for us
into the film
um because you're not having that in our
memories in our sort of energy before we
go out into this Mission it's sort of
felt like we were set up really
beautifully and Rita was just so
instrumental to that sorry but the days
where one man behind the wheel if a car
can make a difference are over
it's time to prepare for what's coming
you might want to buckle up
Alan Daniela congratulations on the film
um Alan I'll start with you it's a
testament to your acting and your
performance let me just say your
character inspires immediate dislike
beam it yeah dislike and I will say it
gets under my skin watching but even
like like Dom Vin Diesel the man who is
just cool as cucumber why do you think
he inspires this just like an instant it
is
and also this is what most people say
no I know you're such a nice man
remember my skin instantly I don't know
you yet but I'm sorry character the
character no that's great that's I feel
like maybe I did my job
uh I don't think
you know did I get under his skin I mean
on screen on screen you definitely I
think that's definitely immediately like
he was just like okay I don't like this
guy I don't know about it but it's sort
of the opposite in comparison to you I
will say I think every girl who's
watched a fast and furious movie dreams
about the day they can line up next to
Vin Diesel on a street race and then you
get the added bonus of Jason Momoa what
was that like it was so cool I felt just
like such a badass and I was so proud to
I mean to to race with them and to be on
almost like I
at least I felt that I was on the same
level as them but of course I'm not like
yeah I can do this can you drive like
that can you drive actually on my
everyday life I'm always on the limit
and I'm the one like come on if we can
go on I don't know but in Portuguese
would be like 100 why won't we go on 100
you know so I'm very like let's go oh my
God yeah that's like 30 miles an hour
she's actually she drives like a girl no
no no no not at all that sounds
insulting that would be insulting I
remember a little bit about Brazil they
definitely like the pedal to the metal
taxi drivers down there they are
aggressive I believe her that she's
having to to go very far with it um I
also want to talk to you both though
about basically the entire sort of crew
I know you guys are new to the franchise
and joining in at this one talk about
that first day on set because you know
this is getting towards the end and
you're part of these final chapters you
know no pressure
totally I mean anytime you walk into a
world where the family's been together
for 25 years you've it's hard not to be
like
there was such a good energy on set and
then several times was like I think this
feels the energy on set feels better
than it has and you know a long time you
know just it's uh you know in any family
like you know you kind of get into a
cycle where you're just sort of like
you're kind of on autopilot and I don't
know it didn't it felt great it just
felt great and everybody's so welcoming
it was extra scary for me because I was
coming off another film and landed had
to go straight to set to shoot the scene
you know the scene with where I was with
Bree basically all the experts like five
pages of exposition nope so I showed up
I was like oh my God so tired of like so
jet lagged right now I don't know how
this is gonna go didn't know anybody I'm
just sort of thrown right in the fire
and um I know I don't know it worked and
it worked because everybody was like so
like you got this it's okay we're here
for you know and that's what we disliked
you that's where it came from yeah it
was jet lag that you didn't like
separate myself no no that's great I
love it but what about you Daniella was
that your first day was it the racing
scene uh not the racing scene okay but
as I remember my first day I think it
was the scene with Jason that he grabs
me by the hair and everything yeah yeah
the bridge thing wow and I mean Jason is
amazing I I always like the image that I
still remember uh about him is he's a
rock star yeah he's not a for me he's
not a movie star like a a superstar he's
a rock star like the the rock is
important yeah yeah uh and on the other
side we have Vin that is super
thoughtful for me I saw like a lot of
spirituality and he's that kind of actor
that pulls you on the side and it's like
what are you what are you feeling what
do you feel about being here are you
grateful you know so it's like very
thoughtful and he he makes us being the
moment and think about this moment that
we're living it's not a thing like we go
there we shoot the movie and then a few
months later we're doing press and we
think about the memories that we had no
we were in the moment thinking about
that so it was really nice so mindful I
I also have to get you to talk a bit
about Jason because I will say
um it has already been said he is
literally I think one of the best male
villains we've seen in this franchise
and that's saying something in the ninth
chapter if you want to talk a little bit
about him he was good he was good uh I
it's funny that she says that because
when I think of Jason on set I think of
the Endless lineup of bass guitars that
he has some kind of a Pixar movie he
just sticks his hand out and somebody
fills it with a bass guitar and he's
like no no no no no while we're blocking
and then he just like action is somebody
grabs and runs up the trouble that you
have to go through to have that many
guitars waiting and like a guitar person
I just want to get to the level where
I'm I have a guitar person
all find ways to sort of like soothe
ourselves through this process
um I think one thing I like to do
especially with a cast this big is
there's so many folks that come from
different things you've seen them from
or new folks that folks are just getting
introduced to but you honestly think
everyone in this they know action they
know heist movies but you want to think
about maybe what something else is like
so instead of asking you like which one
would you want to do for heist which one
of your cast mates would you want to see
do something off type like something
like maybe Vin Diesel doing a musical
maybe like Jason Momoa in a rom-com like
I think there's a lot that like these
guys could do that we haven't seen them
in yet I was just talking about this
with shell last night and we're talking
about she's like I want to get into
comedy I think she is so funny oh I
think she would be so good at that and
it's kind of unexpected because she
plays like the you know the tough
brooding kind of awesome badass chick
but to you know she's like an animated
character when you talk to her oh my God
I think you're absolutely right because
she's kind of got that in Dungeons and
Dragons she's kind of doing a little bit
of calm I dig that what about you
anything you'd like to see somebody in
like different
Helen Mirren in a musical would be cute
in my opinion or like Brie Larson in a
horror comedy yeah
I would say
Tyrese on uh
drama I actually I can see that I could
see him doing like a nice like like
really serious like courtroom procedural
type thing I can dig that I can dig that
Jason Momo in a Hallmark movie oh my
gosh that one let's bring that to life
[Music]
he's trying to tear us apart
you bring and a bit of royalty to
everything you do but especially to
Queenie in this one well you know her
name Queenie was a kind of a riff on
doing the queen obviously but also my
aunt was called Queenie oh and
um and my mom on my mother's side we
come from a very old working-class
London family so Queenie is actually a
very old working class kind of um
English name London name oh I do love
that because on our side is just like oh
of course that's exactly but I do have
to say when you really think about it I
heard someone say it's like well I would
never picture the woman who you know
played the queen to do it actually it
was like really you have a long history
with action and adventure I think you've
always been yearning to do more
physicality has that been what these
later chapters are is really you like
hearkening to something you've always
wanted to do because you've really since
read leaned into this a lot very much so
I mean I love I love watching action
films I think they're so creative I
believe stunt people should get um Oscar
nominations because nowadays so many
films depend completely on the design
and the execution of stunt work so um
and I find it very creative and the
incredible fun to be a part of and and
to watch the way a great stunt is put
together but also as an audience you
know I I mean I mean all I sort of gasp
I'm excited to be a part of that
creativity you know is is wonderful and
it's it's obviously it's very different
from having a three-page monologue you
know or creating a character like the
queen or like gold or you know many of
the other roles that I've played it's an
incredibly sort of fun way to earn a
living and I and I will say this like
looking at something like you know 1923
where it's like it's your melding of the
two it's you're melding those incredible
active performances with Incredible
action you know yes I never thought of
that but you're absolutely right it's a
great acting role and and hopefully you
know already has been you know there's a
lot of action and hopefully we'll be
hopefully we'll be more in the future
yeah I love that and one thing I also
want to add to this too with everything
that you sort of bring to this is you
know they really sort of talk about the
family of it and and obviously you have
ties to that one but I love hearing that
you were the biggest action fan because
there's so many great action sequences
that you are I would say more adjacent
to than a part of but are there ones
that about this franchise or any action
movie that you sort of like stand out
and say as somebody that's really
admiring of The Craft I'm sure there's
ones that you like stick in your mind
and like oh I loved that stunt that was
just stunt in the last fast I think it
was the last false film or the one
before that
um and it was a a car stunt that I of
course it was a cup
clearly it was you know hard hard
you know what it was read it it was red
and it was a stunt where it was because
it was Bruce yeah who sort of jumped out
of the car as the car was moving round
it was an amazing moment and I mean I
never I didn't watch them do that stunt
but I I just it was like mind-blowing
how did you do that how was that
possible it was and of course in Fast
and Furious you have many moments like
that where you you're just you know
you're just in awe I love that and I
will say as much as the family expands
through all of these installments it's
so refreshing to hear that family
members enlist others because I've heard
Charlie say on multiple occasions if
Helen does it I'm signed up so basically
anytime you want to do these you know
that you have a partner in toe is that
kind of like kind of a bonus with this
like a cooler for the end Queenie turned
out to be Charlize his mother wouldn't
that be cool I mean are we talking away
in the background I've heard I've heard
several pictures today from movies and I
will say everyone that y'all come up
with I feel like the folks at like Peter
and Donna already know these pitches